she's 48-0 48 no okay so Jade break this
down
the brace the 50. it's gonna happen it's
gonna happen hell we might as well brace
ourselves for a hundred at this point
and you're familiar with the run that
Goldberg was on like in like when I was
a kid I'm familiar I'm very familiar I I
feel like they're kind of setting you up
to have a similar path yeah I can see
that but like this is Jade cargo's show
so like I that sounds great and
everything's phenomenal phenomenal uh
wrestler he was but he was okay let's be
well okay this is my legacy
he looked apart yeah he did hey I looked
apart but I'm only gonna get better like
and all the women that I'm being
compared to they've been doing this for
five six seven eight years with the best
trainers repetition House shows and I'm
just out there just winging it and doing
the best I can on live TV I think
everybody should be grateful that
they're seeing this product come to
light right so for people who don't know
uh you're fairly new to wrestling yes uh
how long before like was it Mark Henry
that found you yes how long like are we
talking here from like the first time
you got into a a gym and started trying
to learn how to take bumps and yeah and
stuff like that to now
two years so it's not even that not even
that not even that not even that and
like most so other promotions right
there's well the big the big other big
promotion right there's House shows
throughout the week yeah that aren't on
TV so people can kind of like learn
without it being like memed with the
same partner yes right yeah you usually
on the house shows you always are
wrestling with the same person you guys
you know that you're on TV with so
you're just kind of like really out here
obviously you're training when you're
not on TV but like all your high
pressure situations you're we're kind of
going through it with you yeah I mean
for example the first time I used a
chair I remember uh CM Punk was like you
have to choke it up like this and like
because they were like oh yeah you're
gonna use a chair I was I'm gonna use a
chair I've never used a chair in my life
how do I use a chair and no one gave me
instructions other than him to show me
how to use a chair and I had to perform
this on live TV and we'll see in punks
ago that's why yeah yeah so
you you use the chair for the first time
ever ever on TV on TV how'd that goes uh
it was pretty interesting that was a
pretty I that was uh last year let's
just move forth I've learned my lesson
and uh it's gonna get better because how
because for people because there's a an
art to everything yes and I'm a huge
wrestling fan and I always tell people
like
I feel like wrestling is one of the most
D like it it is Art it is I love that
you said that yes it is it is an art
form that is of the highest difficulty
physically uh mentally mentally all of
that stuff uh and there is an art to
everything you guys do including how to
hit somebody with a [ __ ] chairs yeah
don't kill them yeah so how do you do it
I can't tell you that what you're trying
to get me like caught up over here but I
will say that is it is an art you don't
want to completely destroy your opponent
where they can't come back next week and
perform or something like that but it's
all in our we're artists and we're
trying to paint a picture for a story of
course that our audience can follow and
just respect and of course like you have
to you guys have to trust each other in
the ring because yes everybody is trying
to get home at the end of the day yes
yeah very much so